-I've been doing a lot of press
for "That's My Jam."
"That's My Jam" --
season two premieres Tuesday.
I've been doing press.
I've been doing a lot of
radio interviews and TV
interviews and stuff like that.
And this morning,
I was on one of our pal's,
"Elvis Duran
and The Morning Show."
And I went on there --
I love him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi, Danielle, hi, Gandhi.
A great crew over there.
And they wanted to play a game,
and they said,
"This is such a dumb game
that we're playing."
And I go, "I love dumb games.
What is it?"
And it's called,
"I'm thinking of a pasta."
[ Laughter ]
That's the name of the game.
And I go, "Okay."
And so, the whole idea is,
Elvis was just thinking of
a pasta, and I had to guess.
So I thought -- I said,
"I want to take that game.
I want to play it on
'The Tonight Show,'"
and he goes, "You'd be out of
your mind to take that game."
And I am out of my mind,
so here we go to play the game.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's do it.
So, I want to play the game.
Higgins, Tariq, Questlove,
you want to play with me?
I'm gonna write down a pasta.
-Okay.
-I'm thinking of a pasta, okay?
Eh-huh, mm-huh, mm-huh.
[ Laughter ]
Mm-huh, mm.
-Wait a second.
-I don't want
to give anything away.
All right.
Now, here we go.
I'm thinking of a pasta.
Questlove, what pasta --
Oh, how 'bout this?
If you guess it right,
everyone in the audience
gets a pint of
Tonight Dough Ben and Jerry
ice cream?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm just saying!
You want to let
these people down?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, man.
Come on, dude!
All right.
I'm thinking of a pasta.
-Man, that's a lot of pressure.
-I'm thinking of a pasta.
Here we go.
-Whoa.
-All right.
And it falls on me to guess it.
-Well, we have you, Tariq,
and then Higgins, yeah.
But I'm thinking of a pasta.
-All right.
I'll go easy.
I'll say rigatoni.
-Ooh.
-Not true.
Not good, not good.
It is not rigatoni.
Thank you very much.
Come on, focus up.
Tariq?
[ Laughter ]
I am thinking of a pasta.
-Okay.
Okay.
I'm gonna say, uh...
fusilli.
-Ooh!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-What are you talking about?
Fusilli?
You thought that's the pasta
I'm --
-Because you're silly.
I figured silly, fusilli.
All right, whatever, man.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm thinking of a pasta!
Higgins, we've known each other
for 25 years.
You are Italian.
-Yes.
-You've been to Italy.
-We've shared many a meal
together.
I'm thinking of a pasta,
and the audience
is getting ice cream
if you guess it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Higgins,
I'm thinking of a pasta.
-I'm gonna say, since
you've played this once before,
you probably did a fancy one
like fusilli.
And I'm gonna say you're
gonna go, like, every day --
I'm gonna say penne.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Penne!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
♪♪
That was it!
Penne!
Oh, buddy.
-Come on! Come on!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I said!
Penne!
Everyone's going home
with some ice cream!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who likes ice cream?
[ Laughs ]
-Whoo!
-Ah.
I love you, Elvis.